[Music]
are
are we any officially in a second
lockdown at this point
i think we just passed mercury
retrograde okay so we are not in a
lockdown well lockdown is phase one
we're still in phase we moved out of
that so we're in three oh or is
the final after four we're free well we
might be
the whole thing about like everything
closing back down again all right so
was that like us going back to phase one
or anything phase one is you're
completely at home
and it's only essential workers phase
two is uh curbside pickup some
restaurants you can't dine in
phase three is gyms uh with social
distancing
uh uh events without uh what is it an
audience
phase four is now some audiences i think
and then like concerts and all that [ __ ]
could open back up after that one i
guess
or i guess at that point we're free yeah
that got faced too though yeah because i
thought they closed the gems and stuff
oh i guess we are back we went from
phase three to two
okay because indoor dining yeah gyms all
those things we don't do that anymore
how did it last open like a month
three weeks two weeks yeah less than a
month i know i didn't even have time to
do my nails
all right the goal is to always get that
reaction out of you now
you never see me make that face yeah
damn it i was looking down at my nails
too so i missed it but i heard it okay
you just watch the cameras i hit off the
camera though that's it
all
in lockdown if you remembered uh those
of us that were single
uh those of us oh [ __ ] when were we
single don't i think he's talking about
joe
i looked over at them he said
[Laughter]
don't let him do the marketing dude yeah
just you take over the market
he's like all the men out there what do
you want
show a nipple show a nipple there you go
do that open yet there's a lot of gay
dudes trying to
turn these terms turn me gay turn you
straight hey guys
don't knock it see you try it joe what's
going on over there i don't want to try
because they're single that's why
oh right right backed up so so yeah so
during lockdown
uh for single people i i hear that it
was really rough
it's hard to get together with the
girlfriend if you don't live with them
uh it was hard to just meet new people
if you didn't have a girlfriend
so now it's come to light that uh 14
of men during lockdown were yearning for
an intimate relationship
and 14 of men fell in love
with none other than alexa so
her what what as in like the
amazon your species is [ __ ] weird is
this
real your species is weird what's wrong
with ourselves you remember the movie
her
okay yeah it's just like you can't
really speak to alexa though
if alexa was as sophisticated as
scarlett johansson
yeah then maybe maybe yeah but alexis
dumas maybe
because he's the only one woman in the
world that actually listens and does
what they say
why have you then you haven't been with
alexa because she does whatever she
wants
[ __ ] her alexa is an independent why not
siri
why not siri why alexa because alexa's
uh voice was uh sexier
sexier scarlett johansson i guess so i
don't know what alexa sounds like so
what could you fall in love with the ai
yeah because like i've talked to girls
on the phone just primarily like
say uh i could fall in love with a
catfish dude and it was like you talked
to them and
like i haven't seen them because not
from the country but i was like starting
to have feelings for them and i feel
like
that's no different than an ai exactly
yep because ai's learning is learning
you just like a stranger's learning talk
to a person about a call center and be
like
oh girl i'ma go to the philippines thank
you for helping me with my bank problems
my mom got hit up or hit on by the the
credit collector guy that kept going
really yeah he was like he's so like you
know
that's like the worst person to hit up
be like yo you you don't have your
financials in order
so i'm calling now i'm assuming i don't
know the actual story but now i'm
assuming that he approached her
like i'll take care of you baby girl
i'll pay your bills
wow you're not very you're not very
slick
i think i would never offer to pay bills
that's crazy that's a different kind of
game
i'm like you're hot but you got bad
credit oh dear lord
yeah sorry i thought you asked the last
girlfriend how much you cost to buy her
out oh yeah
what the [ __ ]
i've never paid her bills you [ __ ]
couldn't hold that in you [ __ ]
i hope you enjoyed that one
that's so funny i'm saying um you know
that's a different phase in the
relationship
i think i learned my lesson and it's the
early phases now you know like it's a
warning sign when you see somebody and
you're like a
debt collector and you're like no matter
how beautiful you are
oh no if you if you're if you're in debt
i'm scared
yeah i mean she's gonna spend my money
like she's gonna spend her own money
but then like you know it's like what if
you guys get married and you want you
can't assume the worst what if she's
just
down and out and just it was just a lot
of streak of bad luck and then
she just needs a little bit of help on
her feet i assume the worst but
hopefully i'll grow you
i've gotten calls from debt collectors
because i've made dumb decisions
i want to be your friend no more but
like if the girl started hitting me out
she moved away
like it's a [ __ ] disease the girl
started hitting hitting on me through
the phone
you would say yes stop no i'd be like
she's stupid i would i would say yes
just have sex okay then i'm right there
why did you know that that wasn't the
the guy's
perspective too i would have been like
that's only the perspective
yeah i'm yeah okay but you never be like
you don't know how ugly i am
[Laughter]
i don't know if i could [ __ ] up i could
[ __ ] a robot i could [ __ ] around the
robot yeah yeah i mean you don't want to
bounce
but there's no visual to this robot it's
just a
ro it looks like a robot no i have a
hard time falling in love with a human
what makes you think i'm gonna [ __ ]
fall in love with a machine literally
because you can't fall in love with a
human yep
i tried i tried because no human you're
ever going to love
the robot is is it for you because it
because it's made perfectly
it's a program for you robots don't have
[ __ ] though they can
they care with the a.i one's in japan no
do you know what ai
means artificial intelligence yeah it
could be in the cloud
it doesn't have to be i know but like it
could be downloaded in a hot girl
yeah and those are sex thingy robots sex
robots true
i guess you're right i'd rather have
some perfect program
creature if i could download
that ai into a lady like
a real human lady i could i could follow
because think about it right what are
humans [ __ ] ais
really really well they're not well
they're just eyes because they're not
artificial
they're just intelligent oh they're aids
but they're unreliable because you know
people they get heat in them in the
moment and they're not intelligent for
that split second and that's how fights
happen
they're overheating yeah they're just
they're malfunctioned intelligence
yeah am i artificial intelligence you
know what that is
is a [ __ ] influencer that thinks
they're smart
sounds about right nope sounds like me
um all right so with this uh with this
uh
alexa thing uh some men are
so starved of flirting so start of
opportunities to flirt why they don't go
on tinder and [ __ ]
i guess not or like dating maybe maybe
it's a maybe it's a mixture of
them not being the type of guy to go and
oh yeah you know talk to women is there
photos of these men i wanna
there's not photos of these men there's
a whole expose there's there's a there's
a photo of alexa though of
uh really echo if you didn't know what
that you're so fine
isn't she beautiful
i didn't think i'd be able to see
machines this this way
yeah look at how smooth
so uh apparently uh guys are asking
alexa like sexual
uh questions what right trying to get to
like
know her more and things like that and
this has been backed
by people that work at amazon oh yes
listen yes oh my god amazon has released
a statement saying like
uh you know these people are trained uh
that the people listening are trained
to handle this type of sensitive
information
and then why are they listening to begin
with no they're probably listening to
like
the questions being asked or not like
them asking it but it probably comes in
a prompt
yeah it's i think it's like control
quality control of how like alexa works
and stuff like that so they're listening
to
questions and then and then kind of like
seeing if the responses are accurate
right
but then they're also hearing guys like
flirt with alexa now like what like
what's an example i don't know they
didn't give me any examples
but i just thought that was [ __ ]
hilarious like people are so
sexy what's a sexual question like
like what like what could you i don't
know what would you like to be
downloaded
i don't think it's the i don't think
it's the guys that
could get girls out of quarantine that
are doing this
it's just guys that even without
quarantine they couldn't get girls
i don't even think it's sexual honestly
i just think it's companionship and i
think they're probably asking alexa
alexis um alexa alexa okay
i think they're asking her stuff like um
you know like
what do you think about life you know
and they might be having
what movies do you like yeah [ __ ] like
that like first date questions yeah i
think they miss a connection more so
than [ __ ]
damn well he didn't say sexual questions
oh that never makes me think like what's
the sexual question
what if i'm over connected uh what does
that mean
i feel over connected what does that
mean too much
talking not enough [ __ ] more
quarantine well then that wouldn't be
these guys
no so they want they're i get too much
[ __ ]
i just want to have a conversation these
girls they just always want one thing
i know they ask one question for sure
what is it alex is my dick big enough oh
yeah
it's like she's like oh my god i want to
see the response or the all the
questions like the highlights i know i
kind of want to bring in an alexa
who has an alexa question these guys
are tired and sick of all these
quarantined horny girls
and they're like what when is it when am
i going to meet a woman who just wants
me for me my mind and then he starts
talking to alexa it's like oh
here's someone that isn't always horny
let's have a conversation and then they
get romantic
and then he's like now i want to have
sex with you
because he's like what do you want to
eat for dinner yeah there's going to be
some bad habits though
what is that because like okay now
imagine uh say
if you're on a date right uh and then
now every time the guy
asks you anything every single time he
says hey tiff
and then ask you that because she won't
respond until you say hey alexa
every single time you have to ask it's
pretty polite that's funny and it's kind
of materialistic because the only way
he communicates and gets something from
it is through amazon
true and so in the end jeff bezos wins
yeah everyone's actually in love with
best bezels oh like you have to take a
girl out on a date and like pay for her
food yeah you have to pay for the
electricity like turn her on
yeah to turn her to turn her on and
technically alexa's underage
because this article made it a point to
say that alex is only five years old
oh weird so why would they do well maybe
in electric years
is there photos it's like dog years
right every year it's about 20.
there we go i like that she's 100. it is
of like that two times five
oh [ __ ] she's a hundred technology does
move really fast yeah she's
old in light speed and i like you know
electricity runs fast so
what's her programmed age five years ago
five years out
[Music]
foreign